I was ball man hello and welcome to the
lab where we take your questions and
turn them into experiments my name is
Mitch and I'm Greg and today we're gonna
be conquering one of our greatest fears
which is the fear of heights
specifically we're gonna be climbing one
of the tallest freestanding structures
in the Western Hemisphere and finding
out what would happen if we fall off the
fear of heights is also known as
acrophobia and the symptoms include
dizziness nausea shaking so we're gonna
test these things on ourselves by going
up to CN tower going outside of it and
walking around the edge the CN Tower is
an iconic part of Toronto's skyline and
stands at 553 meters high it's also
Drake's favorite chair the long pointy
end 10 abortion was actually made up of
26 pieces each which were brought up by
a helicopter but where we'll be
completing the edge walk is on the top
of the main pod which is 356 metres
above the ground and is the highest
external walk of a building in the world
for reference would be like stacking the
white house on top of itself
approximately 17 times and then walking
around on top
site limit I'm nervous that's what we're
going on in a couple of seconds and I
realize I haven't I'm not that nervous
but seeing it when I got here I'm scared
but I'm not I'm not scared at all yeah
you're scared I know you are just trying
to be the bear our brains are basically
anticipation machines and we use
information from our past and our
current state and environment to help
predict the future which ultimately
helps us to stay alive
Mitch is signing away his life hopefully
you don't fall off but when you don't
have any experience with the thing that
you're anticipating like I've never been
hundreds of meters in the air walking on
an edge that I could die off of then
your fear goes up and so does your
fight-or-flight behavior I thought you
were nervous a lot of our fears stem out
of learned experiences or traumatic
ffensive happened to us but the fear of
heights is said to be much more common
in people and it's actually something
that we're born with one that we go up
in the elevator is when I go Rick I
don't feel like I'm just wearing a cool
suit scientists have actually used
studies and experiments with visual
cliffs and they studied domestic animals
and toddlers and found that out of very
young age they're very cautious around
these cliffs showing that the fear of
heights is something that we're born
with I mean it makes sense that the fear
of heights is natural and something that
we're born with because it protects
ourselves and makes us live longer so
that we don't walk off cliffs or walk
off the CN Tower
the third yeah right there push your
rope all the way out in front of you and
then lean forward into that room keep
going all the way forward excellent and
then you can let go awesome job bitch
[Music]
okay so this is amazing horrifying
freaking out but imagine if you out well
a seventy seven kilogram person falling
from 356 meters would reach speeds of up
to three hundred kilometers an hour and
reached the bottom in under nine seconds
that is without any drag or force acting
opposite to the relative motion of a
moving object top terminal velocities
for human skydivers are lower because of
air resistance around 195 kilometers an
hour Windham facing stomach to earth and
they don't reach this speed until around
12 seconds or after traveling 450 meters
either way it wouldn't take long to hit
the bottom it's no surprise that you
likely wouldn't survive this fall though
some humans have lived to tell the tale
after falling from very high heights in
fact there's actually been reports of
people falling from over 5,000 meters
mostly during the war so out of burning
airplanes but they landed on pine trees
or soft snow or glass roofs and they
also had a lot of injuries it ultimately
depends on if the surface you land on
has high deformity like snow then your
chances for survival increase okay I
feel less less dizzy and scared now yeah
I feel more confident that we've had
some time to spend just and kinda
becomes normal after a while and I'm
like what's that but every time I have
to go on the edge I've done genuine fear
with the toes over the edge yeah that
may see one throw it was a crazy
experience but super cool we're so glad
we did it conquered a fear
well
[Music]
you